[Applause]
bucks with two timeouts boston just used
their last timeout
here we go tatum guyana switches onto
him
potato monado kumpo the superstar step
back three on the way
oh it banks in jason tatum
puts boston on top with a
window three how about that
seconds remaining turned into a
one-on-one
game the best defender on the bucks goes
up against the best offensive player on
boston taking their time getting the
best shot
available his patented move we've seen
tatum do that in and out
left dribble step back to the left angle
and yeah the bank's open you can act
like you're meant to hit that off the
glass
the words of paul pierce i didn't call
glass
heads on to the postseason as well so if
you finish seven or eight
one win gets you in tatum to them
i guess he's got tired of all that can
do this
yes indeed he just
that's that's power and jumping ability
you've got two of the top ten players in
the game
getting ready to come back that's why i
wouldn't be sweating where they are
right now
what a pass inside here comes thompson
lurking there with kuzma
who collapses on tristan i mean this
young man is just so gifted
oh that's beautiful
[Music]
hachimura will defend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr lopez right
up and watch him give it a little love
cap to his boy
nice play by pritchett gets it back in
the hands of tatum
tatum spins on the baseline goes hard to
the basket gets two and a foul
[Applause]
the post up is what he wanted he spins
he gets the contact
the focus and the finish
jason tatum puts the celtics up by one
with a chance for a three-point play
look at the patience the poise
what a big time sequence from the layup
so the two layups the fat the steal
would beal
and now the go ahead bucket
tatum out near the midcourt line hard
all over them
[Applause]
tatum into the pain the floater good
tied
with point two to go jason
tatum josh hart makes you catch the ball
at half court you are under duress of
the shot clock
and an excellent individual player he
makes you put it on the deck and make
maybe the toughest shot in basketball a
floater on the move
from eight feet let me just put it easy
in the bucket come on folks are you
kidding me
he's 22 years of age over the
outstretched arms
you're talking about big time offensive
talent
seven six tatum
stops and fires and fills it with 2.9
well milk the clock that's exactly what
they did
now you give it to your option 118
with the good ball handle and the
ability to create his own stuff and
that's exactly what
jason tatum was able to do here
strong left and usually when guys that
are right-handed go left they're going
to pull up
tatum little stutter step cross over
step back three-pointer punch it in
jason tatum on fire
he's got 38. 13 of 23 from the field
and the celtics down 0-2 with his
best-of-seven series
yeah seven points and six minutes and a
level of aggression
oh the no look from tatum to pritchard
who lays it in
five points off your bench already tatum
the nice pass to pritchard
oh you mean we got guys who play to the
media
oh and a pass from tayton and williams
with the finish
that was sensational
what a passion
just perfectly leading robert williams